if i may i would like to tell you a true
story
a story about a house that
had a bad room what they call an island
a bad room it had an atmosphere
people were loathe to go into it
they didn't wish to have anything to do
with it
and if people heard about this room and
they wanted to go and see it
the people of the house would say please
don't go near the room and if you do go
near the room
always go with somebody because it has
some sort of fatal attraction
to draw those people in
and people would open the door and let
people look into the room
and the sense of attraction to that room
was like a magnetic pull
they would want to go in and that is why
the other person was there always to
stop them
and then one young foolish man decided
against all advice
that he would spend the night in the
room
and people pleaded with him
scolded him shouted at him screamed with
him fought with them
and he said no i will spend the night in
the room
to rid us all of this superstitious
rubbish
and he went in to that room
and the door without any
human being touching closed
behind
and they all waited
and they all waited until about six
o'clock in the morning
and from that room there was the most
horrendous
soul destroying screen
and they all rushed up to the room and
they opened the door
and there was nothing there at all
no sign of the young man
except a pungent smell
of animal and brimstone
mixed together and lying on the floor
was a shoe that's all
nothing more and the story was printed
in the paper and people
came to hear about it and
eventually it got to the ears of one of
the great jesuits
who was an exorcist and he decided
that he would go to this room and he
would attempt
to exercise this evil this presence this
prince of darkness whatever it might be
that was in that room and again the
people pleaded they said no and he said
no
i shall do it but if by chance
something happens to me in this room if
the pattern
is the same one of my shoes
will remain in that room and whatever
happens whatever is the secret of the
evil of that room
i will write that upon my shoe
and if i am not there look to my shoe
because the answer to this puzzle
will be upon the shoe and he arrived
entered the room and the door closed
behind
and the people sat down stairs by a fire
and they waited
and the clock this large grandfather
clock
ticked away the time
quietly and from upstairs they could
hear the priest
praying they could smell the incense
and at about 4 30 in the morning
they looked at the dog who was asleep by
the fire
and in his sleep he had begun to growl
and as they looked on them the heckles
on the back of the dog
began to rise
and he gave out the most basel
of hum-like house
and from the room upstairs they heard
the scream
and they ran up with lights it crosses
with crucifixes with holy water
open the door
and all there was was this pungent smell
and a shoe
and they ran to the shoe they picked it
up they turned it over
and burnt into the sole of that shoe
were two words
size nine
i've seen two ghosts in my life i saw a
ghost
at the comedy store and i saw a ghost
when i was about four
in a building in new york you remember
that oh
four yes i still remember what i felt
like
i still remember telling my mother the
confusion that i had
and i still remember my mother asking me
the story over and over and over again
like a cop
to make sure i wasn't [ __ ] crazy and
then when i moved into 35-15 given that
terrace
there was a time when i was when i got
out of catholic school
i couldn't stay in that house bobby lee
you know i couldn't stay in that house
at night
yeah probably i'm a big boy you know me
you know i'm the type of guy i love to
be independent
when i go to the catholic school when i
got out of the catholic school
my mom had a bar so that meant basically
i had the
house to myself at nights what 12 year
old kid
what 12 year old kid doesn't want a
house to himself with cable tv
every every night every kid wants a
house to himself
i would go home at night my mother would
cook dinner i would eat dinner with her
she'd leave to the bar
i would do my homework watch get christy
love whatever show was popular in those
times
go up to my room about 10 o'clock put
the air on go to sleep
and within 20 minutes i'd be awoken by
something
i believe this went on for [ __ ] a
year that i couldn't sleep
i would [ __ ] chase torture and i
would feel something
i would just and one night i said i
can't do this normal there's something
in this [ __ ] house
and i remember telling my mother my
stepfather and people
like you're crazy you're watching too
many horror movies
and i [ __ ] started living with a
family i would just go to the house at
night
i played basketball with the kids and
their parents didn't have a [ __ ] clue
who was in their couch at night so you
could you couldn't sleep i would go to
my mother's bar stay at my mother's bar
until nine do homework eat dinner with
my mother
and then go to 26th street from central
there were a puerto rican family
named the torrez's and i was somewhat
jose torres papa
and i'd go to his room we'd watch tv and
nobody would know i was even sleeping in
this house i'd get up in the morning
brush my teeth
comb my hair and go to north bergen
school so i would stay in union city
and go to school in north bergen the
[ __ ] point of the story is
yeah that after my mother died
and i found the dead and the whole thing
i found out an interesting [ __ ] story
some people came over after my mom died
and they said we're really sorry about
your mom's death
and they said you know what we never
liked this house anyway we thought about
buying this house
but you know why this house sold for
cheap because somebody hung themselves
in the
right there i knew that all my
premonitions that i had i would hear it
bobby lee
i'm not a [ __ ] i'm not a [ __ ] idiot
bobby lee i know what i see
and i know what i feel i would feel
somebody going up the steps
wow that's what i would feel people
running up the steps and running down
the steps now the person that killed
himself was they were they white
i had no idea you have to know that [ __ ]
you have to know that [ __ ] probably new
jersey you would think so right i
thought he hung himself
for years i heard the room because after
like my mother died
they buried it and these people who had
lived on the block i knew
like i wasn't friendly with them yeah
they came that day and we're like
we looked at this house first it was
like 10 000 cheaper
yeah but somebody killed themselves in
the garage so yeah uh they said he hung
himself and then i told somebody and
they came back to me they're going
on we did some looking the guy was one
of those guys that uh
closed the garage oh and put the [ __ ]
car on the car on so anytime i go back
to that house like when
i shot the documentary i could feel
that house like i was thinking about
buying that house
but then i'm still there i'm buying that
house it's still there yeah
it's still there and i'm thinking of
going back to north bergen and saying
what do you want for this house
and offer them 20 000 more got that
house
there's a shadow somewhere
i think it was in america yeah and it's
on a quiet road
i'm guessing somewhere like boston
that's why you mentioned
something like boston and people at
night used to see this shadow moving
about
and they'd go what's that right and it
got known that the town the little local
town got known for the shadow but it
didn't cause any problems
people what are you talking about it was
just you lost me what are you talking
about
you know some places get famous like uh
scotland's got the loch ness monster on
that but it doesn't cause anything
but it doesn't cause any problems that's
exactly right so there's this shadow
walking about on the road
what do you mean what's he again rubbish
right so he's talking
about where did you read this this was
on the internet and
oh sorry sorry
i thought it was shite i didn't know it
was on the internet
right so this shadow is moving about and
uh independently i'm an object
yeah and the local mayor and that is
like yeah it's a bit weird but it's not
harming anyone
ah the mayor involved was he connected
to that post
hey hey mayor look at the problem down
here seems like a shadow
wow it's not cause anybody no it's just
causing any problems yeah that's but
that's the thing it was
left for years and then it did start
causing problems i see that's it if you
leave these shadows to go and check rick
they go crazy yeah you let them run amok
and you say yeah you've got a staff
it was pushing people off the bikes
it was what it was pushing people off
the bikes
i'll find out more for that next week
right now you're romania we'll do more
on that
we haven't had time for education
just promise me now you'll never have
kids oh [ __ ] i gotta tell you the story
i um
i always look at houses you know i'm not
going to sell my house i love this
[ __ ] place as much as i [ __ ] that's
why i [ __ ] about it because i love this
[ __ ] house
and um and i'm going to continue to
[ __ ] repair it and i'm going to do
the [ __ ] homeowner 360. and when i
have the whole thing fixed i'm gonna
start over again on the first job
because now it's gonna be [ __ ] up
uh whatever i repaired at that point
will then be [ __ ] up so anyways
i um there was this house for sale
and uh i went to go i went to go see it
and it basically
had everything that you could ever want
right it's a beautiful house you know
from the outside
it was a beautiful house it had a
[ __ ] pool it had a garage detached
from the house with a room above it
which to me is like oh there you go i
got the kid
i got the house with the i got the
garage with the [ __ ] room above it
i put my drums up there turn it into a
drum room slash podcast room
there you go that is my [ __ ] dream so
i go over to go look at this [ __ ]
place
right knowing full well i'm not gonna
[ __ ] buy it
because i can tell at this point having
bought a [ __ ] house that needed all
the work it does but as
as i'm driving up to it i can already
see the [ __ ] windows need to be
replaced and it needs a new roof
even though they told me you know we
checked out the roof there we had some
inspectors they said it's fine
oh yeah is that what they said
why are all these water stains all over
the side of the [ __ ] house
what's that about i like how the windows
don't [ __ ] quite
they're not flush look at that look at
the rot around all of those [ __ ]
windows
this house i can tell you right now is
already a borderline teardown
and i haven't even gotten into it yet so
i walk into this [ __ ] house and holy
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude i i took a tour
of this house there was three separate
times that i thought i was gonna get
murdered
all right first of all we go to look at
the room above the garage first and
there's just this
this moss growing on the side of the
house which i don't know if it was
mold or if it was moss it was [ __ ]
green
and um the guy trying to sell it is you
know he's doing his best going you know
it's a mother-in-law suite
you can [ __ ] do this you can do that
there's room to add a little more under
the garage and i just point
to the i'm like what is that and he goes
yeah well you know he
definitely needs a little bit of work
and uh so i go into the house
and there's this random guy in there who
isn't the owner as a
ponytail it's sparsely furnished it was
made in the 1920s so it's already like
creepy you can already feel how many
people have lived there and are now
dead and uh
we just walk around the house it got
remodeled sometime in the 90s yet it
still had the [ __ ]
uh you know long cheney jr vibe of it
from the 20s
and uh i go downstairs it was like a
basement which they just don't have out
here
and uh the guy's like you can make this
into a tv room and there was all like
these
[ __ ] files and film and all this [ __ ]
down there
and like you know that was the first
time i was thinking about like uh saw
or the blair witch and i'm like all
right uh can we go back upstairs so we
go back upstairs we go all the way
upstairs
then there was this random like teenage
girl living there that was the daughter
of the dude downstairs who wasn't
[ __ ] who lives there
but i don't know it's not his house and
we look up there and there's this stuffy
[ __ ] smell
and then as we go down to go to the
master bedroom they said oh the owner
is uh the owners just let you know the
owner is there
he's in the house which usually they
[ __ ] leave
there's all these people just there and
this [ __ ] cat just sitting there
looking at me
and i do the after you to go to the
master bedroom and he does the after you
to me and then i didn't want to be rude
so now i'm walking towards
the master bedroom down this creepy
[ __ ] transylvania hall
with the the with the [ __ ] the guy
smiley real estate agent behind me
who you know he's the i'm sitting there
going like he's regular looking good
looking guy
that was to make me feel safe and now
i'm [ __ ] and i'm walking towards this
[ __ ] door
and i open the [ __ ] door
and i look in there and i swear to god
there's this guy
with like gray skin
totally [ __ ] bald like the landing
strip and then like you know
like the little [ __ ] uh mr whipple
[ __ ] hair
around the side that he sort of died at
some point but now it was like this gray
he was totally gray you could see the
veins on the side of his head like clint
eastwood
but not like i wouldn't want to fight
clint eastwood more like did this guy
die and then come back and he was
sitting down hunched down i think he was
typing on the side of his bed the place
was a mess he just sort of looked over
me just
like hey he looked like the [ __ ]
dad in uh the texas chainsaw
massacre and i was just like what the
[ __ ]
so i went like hey hey man how are you i
sort of stepped around him and then
when i went to look into the bathroom
which i did for [ __ ] two seconds
you know trying to feel the backside
pressure by the way
you know like when a quarterback doesn't
feel the rush you know trying to feel
that [ __ ] axe that was about to go to
my back
i look into the bathroom and all
along the bathtub this guy had knee-high
dress socks
drying on it and i was just like
ah and i was just like all right man
i'll [ __ ]
see you later and i did i
did you ever see that walk racing that
that was a big fad in the 70s i did that
right out of that [ __ ] house
and i told i said a real estate guy i go
jesus christ i can see why this has been
on the market for so [ __ ] long
how the [ __ ] he's supposed to sell it
when the goddamn creep kipper keeper
keeper the crypt keeper i'm like
verbally dyslexic forget about trying to
read
um it's sitting up there
i didn't dare look you know i was
standing there and i said all this [ __ ]
i know those old houses you can hear
everything when you're outside i was
standing right underneath the [ __ ]
bedroom window
and i didn't dare look up there because
i had a feeling he was gonna be standing
in the window staring at me and i was
gonna have [ __ ] nightmares
and uh and i just i just i [ __ ] left
i left and i have this creepy [ __ ]
feeling that because i went into that
house i got exposed to something
and at some point today my home phone
which i never use so it never [ __ ]
rings
is gonna ring and i'm gonna pick it up
and it's going to be that guy's voice
going chevron days
and then i got to somehow expose
somebody i know to it so i don't [ __ ]
die
having said that it was a great house
that had a lot of potential
[Music]
you